yesterday, at a meeting of the security site,
we once again circulated an
official document that
confirms our serious
concern about the facts
reflecting the provocative actions of the
Ukrainian side,
that they say that we
will blow ourselves up while at a nuclear
facility. Well, is it necessary to comment on this?
for many months
they have been constantly on a rotating
basis experts are rich
these experts
send to vein to the headquarters of the MGT
regular reports can do this at least
on a daily basis it is their decision these
experts, as well as
the general director of the
MGT Grosse who visited the Zaporozhye NPP, know very well who is
shelling the Zaporizhzhya nuclear plant
Recently, such
shelling has become much less at the bus station But they
were regular until quite recently and
they are well aware that it is dangerous And that
this good may not bring to our
national interest Thank you for
worrying but you should not do this
Russia is always out of any trouble And this is
louder  than troubles it is difficult to call
it came out stronger stronger it
will be And this time more than that we already
feel that this process has begun All
the children who are now in their
parental territory they are all known
their names no one
hides  these children have
direct parents or relatives, they
have every right to take these children to pick up
what is already being done and has been done more than once
several dozen children returned to
their relatives when they showed up
but in Russia They ended up because they
were in orphanages
and no relatives were
around there  and orphanages, we really
evacuated together with the staff, along
with the educators,
and the combat zones